SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: It is a
pleasure for me to be here in
Shanghai to engage in this
conversation that was really
inspired by William Fung, who
is a member of the class of
1970 at Princeton, and currently
a trustee at the
university.
I think he described brilliantly
the rationale for
these conferences that we hope
to have in cities around the
world in the years to come.
It's really intended to
spark conversation.
So we hope that this will be the
beginning of a wonderful
series of conversations in which
Princeton engages with
some of the most important
questions facing our world.
EDWARD GLAESER: Now the success
the dynamism, the
significance of cities
throughout the world today is
something of a paradox, because
we live in an age in
which distance is dead,
in which we could all
effortlessly telecommuting in
from whatever sylvan spot
appeals to our biophilia.
And yet, in so many ways, in so
many places, we choose the
inconveniences of city life.
The cyber-seers and the
techno-prophets in the 1980s
predicted that the internet
would all make us revert back
to electronic cottages.
And yet, the opposite seems
to have happened,
and that's a paradox.
Why has the ability to
communicate and connect over
long distances actually
made proximity
more, not less, valuable?
Why hasn't it meet face-to-face
contact that
cities enable more, not
less, valuable?
Now this rosy view of cities
was very different from the
New York of my youth.
This is an image of Detroit from
1967, the year which I
was born, in which the city
was in flames, in which it
appeared that civilization
itself, a creation of a city,
had fled to greener pastures.
This reflected the decline in
transportation cost during an
earlier era, the move of
industry from older urban
areas to suburban areas, to
lower cost states within the
US, and then to lower cost areas
throughout the country.
We have seen the process of
industrial cities hollowing
out throughout the globe.
And indeed, this is something
that China will eventually
also have to face.
JUAN DU: What I want to point
out to you, and since this
panel is talking about planning
in some ways, the
actual population in
1979 was 300,000.
And the master plan that was
created at the time by the
central government, and by the
Tianjin civil government,
planned a population
for one million.
That means all of the roads,
all of the facilities--
hospitals, housing,
et cetera--
was forming for one million.
But actually, by the year 2000,
the actual population of
Tianjin was 10 million.
So 10 times the demand
on all civic
infrastructure and civic services.
This is a map published in
Tianjin officially by
government, and it's the central
economic zone in the
year 2000, because this is the
City Hall, which is a giant
building that covers
a huge city block.
I want to draw your
attention to this.
This is right off the
axis of the symmetry
of the central CBD.
This looks like a typical
luxury housing
development in the city.
However, this is the
actual condition.
So this map was published
in the year 2007.
This satellite photo
was the year 2010.
So 10 years difference between
what was planned and reviewed
as the actual versus
what is the real.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GYAN PRAKASH: So we are back
to the soft city--
the soft city of myths,
dreams, illusions,
imaginations, dreams,
nightmares.
We're talking about cinema.
And cinematic expression has profoundly
shaped our
visions of urban life.
A new generation of film makers
have emerged to provide
fresh depictions and reflections
on the city.
ANDREW JARECKI: I found, at
least in my experience, that
the city can be an extremely
important character in a film.
Certainly, anybody that's seen
a film made in India knows
that it's almost the only thing
that an American can
think of when you watch a
film, whether it's like
popular, like Slumdog
Millionaire, or something more
sophisticated.
And certainly, for me, New York
City has been like that,
because I grew up in New York,
and I was raised there, and I
had all my summer jobs when
I was a kid walking
around Times Square.
And so, I started writing this
screenplay for this film
called All Good Things, and
always had New York City in my
mind, having a particular focus
on the center of the
city, which I think of
as Times Square.
ANURAG KASHYAP: So my
first experience
with a city was quite--
when I moved to Bombay to get
into the movies, I was kind of
very awed by the city, which I
think is quite visible in my
first film.
So for me, a city was always this
strange creature, because I
never saw those tall buildings
I never grew up with them.
MICHAEL OPPENHEIMER: One of the
things we know with great
certainty is we have increased
exposure along the coast, we
have put more infrastructure
and people in vulnerable
situations, and that over time,
we expect that exposure
to even grow more and more.
And as a result, quantifiable
damages, monetizable damages--
from tropical cyclones,
for instance--
have increased, and it's
not yet due to
any big climate change.
It's not due yet, we believe,
due to an overall change in
vulnerability.
It's the business of letting
more and more people settle in
vulnerable situations
where they are
exposed to these hazards.
So there, again, the
combination.
Risk is from the concatenation
of vulnerability and exposure
with the physical changes
in the climate system.
A storm not as bad as Sandy at
the flood level, instead of
11.3 feet, was about 9 feet--
you can convert
it to meters yourself--
happened in 1992.
It was a hundred-year storm
instead of a thousand-year.
This is the Hoboken, New
Jersey-- right across from the
river from New York City--
subway station that
got flooded.
A friend of mine was in the
station at the time.
He didn't take this picture.
But he literally ran
for his life.
He almost drowned, and after
that, the city got very
concerned about plugging the
tunnels, keeping the water out
of subways, raising the
ventilations gratings,
plugging the highway tunnels.
And then slowly over the years,
the energy just drifted
out of the system.
DENISE MAUZERALL: This is
photographs taken in Beijing a
couple of weeks ago.
And it's quite a common sight.
To see people with
masks like this.
This is not that common sight.
But the visibility is
enormously impaired.
With Professor Zhu Tong, I
took the fast train to Beijing
to Shanghai on Tuesday when the
measured PM 2.5 was about
500 micrograms per
cubic meter.
And across the entire region,
the visibility
was enormously impaired.
There were times frequently
during that trip where we
couldn't see 50 feet
outside the window.
In the year 200, about half
a million people died
prematurely from their
exposure to aerosols.
If business as usual continued,
about three
quarters of a million would.
If the current legislation was
perfectly enforced, you'd
return in 2030 to the
levels of 2000.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: It's
been an extraordinary
privilege to be a part
of this conference.
And I know from the
conversations with all of you
that this conference has
launched a set of
relationships and dialogues that
will persist long beyond
it across fields, as well
as across oceans and
international boundaries.
I want to, in my returning to
Mario Small's question that I
declined to even try to answer
earlier about how we can have
conversations about the right
level of both complexity,
given the problems that we're
facing, and interdisciplinary.
Only to link that up to kind
of a paradox that has
resonated through this
conference, which is that in
an age when virtual
communication has become more
possible, and, when in theory,
we could all interact with one
another without being
in proximity.
The city has become more
important in place.
It's become more important.
That seems to be true of these
conversations, as well as this
conference exemplifies.
So that one of the
responsibilities we have as we
move forward with these problems
is to continue to
look forward, to look for
innovative ways to bring
people together to have these
kinds of conversations that
would not otherwise
take place.
I thank all of you for making
these conversations such an
extraordinary success.
And I think you should give
yourself, as well my fellow
panelists, a round of applause
to finish that.
[APPLAUSE]